[Music]
[Music]
all right Brian hey welcome to this
week's episode of lost origins man we
are so stoked that you took the time out
of your day to join us to talk all
things your background your work your
theories losing a Nobel Prize I'm super
excited to jump into that but just thank
you so much for hopping on with us today
man this could be good yeah thanks guys
no big fan of the work you guys do and
it's an honor to be on the show I
stopped it that's weird that's cool
that's cool so let's do this man one of
the things that we always like to open
the shows with is you know for for
people who maybe have not encountered
your work in the wild or whatnot we
always like to set the stage by giving
you the opportunity to just hit us with
a little bit of a history lesson right
who is Bryan Keating what is the focus
of your work well you know what brought
you to this moment today just that
35,000 foot view why don't you break us
off on some of that real quick yeah I'm
going to give you the 14 billion light
year view 35,000 so earth centric so
what I do and what I've always been
animated by is the same thing that
drives you guys which is the search for
origins and what that means for me
really took on a two-fold mission and
that I want to understand the deepest
possible evidence that one could find
for the origin of the universe and I'd
always been fascinated by that because
it's really the only story if you think
about it every other story from Sherlock
Holmes you know to to you know some
modern-day story he'll daily elegy I
don't know you could think of any story
any nonfiction work it always starts in
the in the middle of the story it always
starts in what's called in media raids
but if the universe had a singular
origin and what we normally think of as
the Big Bang
then time itself didn't exist before
that moment and we now believe we think
we can date that moment very accurately
and let's get into that so I ask the
question you know of myself as a young
kid how would time possibly flow how
could time change if time had a
beginning and that really kind of
impelled me to think about really the
biggest questions that one could answer
potentially answer and and and
thankfully I say I haven't answered them
because it gives me job security these
questions are very difficult to answer
sure and the second type of origin is I
really want to understand my own origins
and really what made me tick and how I
came to be here on earth and both
culturally ethnically however you want
to say it and as a scientist and how
that animates me to be to want to see
and influence my worldview in my
philosophy of life through through the
lens of being a scientist
and those two things animate me very
deeply and drive me to do the work that
I do and the daily tasks that I engage
in yeah really not those that I had
aspired to do with these twin visions
that I just described so most of the day
I'm not sitting around stroking my
non-existent beard pondering the
multiple universes in which we might
inhabit or things like you know signing
a receipt for a travel form for some
trip I took three months ago to San Jose
and you know you're doing very mundane
things and I usually say that my job so
I'm a professor I teach physics and
astronomy at the University of
California San Diego I've been here over
15 years again believe it and and it's
the most wonderful wealth because it
allows me to essentially get paid to do
something I would do for free and did
for free for many decades which is to
look out through telescopes to see what
the early universe looked like that's
amazing I love it and you know what I'm
hearing right now is like when you do
what you love right it's when you're
passionate about your craft it makes it
that much easier to get up and do the
thing every single day and stay
motivated and stay plugged in the the
phrase you know when you love what you
do it's not work I don't agree with that
at all
it's a kind of the opposite in my mind
right it's like no it's it's harder
because you're that much more invested
in continuing to fight the good fight
you know what I mean
right exactly so I already heard that
phrase slightly differently do what you
love you know the money doesn't matter
and then if you only do what you love
you won't have any money to worry about
[Laughter]
you have to strike a balance between
doing something that's practical and I
always joke you know my deepest love was
actually philosophy and trying to
understand you know the meaning of
existence and the essence of you know
the search for truth and and knowledge
yeah but I was bewildered by the
overwhelming amount of job opportunities
that have as a philosopher so I never
went in to become a professional
philosopher I'm just kidding about that
that'd be great if philosophers you know
we're as richly rewarded as you know
shortstops in the and they write
shortstops in mumble rappers we got to
we got to adjust some stuff here so just
like hit me with like what'swhat's the
daily Delta look like for you out of
curiosity right like you had mentioned
you know the mundane tasks but like when
you're in the throes of a project or
you're working on trying to answer you
know certain questions or work towards a
goal with a team like what kind of stuff
are you working on give us a little bit
of context for it for some of our
listeners who maybe are not familiar
with the role of an astrophysicist yeah
so perhaps the most familiar job of an
astrophysicist in a university setting
which is that of being a professor
namely a teacher that's the most
commonly and correctly so associated
feature of a professor someone who
teaches and lectures and so but that's a
very small portion of my job you know
that's about three hours a week when
teaching classes you know three one-hour
or we class the other you know in my
case 57 hours a week is really spent as
a small businessman which is involving
all sorts of different tasks from pay
payroll of employees to travel to
logistics we're building the world's
highest cosmological telescope in the
high Andes desert of northern Chile
called the Atacama Desert
but this telescope is a hundred million
dollar class
project is composed of comprised of 260
people on all seven continents and I'm
honored and blessed to be the director
of this project and that means you know
the box milling a hundred million of
them stop with me
not that I get to keep any one of them
but but I have to you know have the
ultimate oversight on how that money is
is obtained and and eventually dispersed
and I rely on the work of a huge team I
mean you think about how big a business
that has a hundred million dollar budget
over you know roughly ten years that's a
decent sized small business and with
that many people distributed in all
seven continents it's a logistical
nightmare to really get all the vendors
all the subcontractors that we're
building this telescope at the world's
highest altitude observatory of its kind
and we're trying to do something not
just you know build a Starbucks at the
top of a mountain this Observatory is
the most exquisite and sensitive and
advanced technologically of its kind
I'll give you one example yeah we have
we have devices called cryo stats so
normal person looks through a telescope
you're using your eye as a detector and
the lenses that are on the telescope are
the telescope itself for us we have
lenses that the human eye can't see
through because we're looking for heat
not light from the Big Bang and our eyes
are not the detectors and said they're
very exotic type form of material called
a superconductor and we don't have
billions of pixels as we do in our eyes
or in the largest optical cameras we
only only quote-unquote have tens of
thousands but each one of those has to
be cooled down to one tenth of a degree
above what's known as absolute zero the
ultimate stopping point in temperature
below which there exist no temperature
just as perhaps before the Big Bang
there exists no time and I hope you're
thinking maybe right now there could be
a connection between the absolute zero
and temperature and the absolute zero
and time and maybe that's something cool
we could talk about there today or next
time the ultimate thing that we do is we
build ultra sensitive technology and
detectors and to do that requires a
tremendous amount of logistical support
design
and capability and the greatest blessing
that I have is the PR the people that I
work with I work with the smartest 260
people in the world I can really say
that these are the most
people I learned from them every day
they range in age from 18 to 80 Wow and
they are some of the most accomplishment
and women as I said from every continent
on Earth including Antarctica so it's
just so it's just a fascinating that
gives me great joy and that I get to
learn from so many people on a daily
basis even if I don't get to really
ponder the universe's deepest darkest
secrets on an hourly basis well and
you're still able to just like subject
yourself and submerge yourself in
amazing technology right like how like
for granted we take things on a daily
basis in like the the civilian world
quote-unquote like I'm a target the
other day just fascinated by the iRobot
Roomba and how this thing is gonna clean
my living room for me without me being
at the helm and you're like playing with
gadgets and technology that is just so
next-level it's it's unbelievable it's
so good so sometimes we have to invent
the technology that's then used to do
the astounding measurements that we're
trying to do so these are you know these
are really at the forefront of human
knowledge and no single person can do
all that and and by the way it's not
only building the technology that is as
complicated as building say you know
Apple's new building in Northern
California yeah there's just a
technological aspect of it maybe even
harder but it's the analysis of data
which is equivalent to you know like
thousands upon thousands of the biggest
hard drives that we have every year yeah
and that that data we can't throw it
away we every single bit and byte of
data is precious and must be mine
because that data originated from the
most ferocious explosive expansion of
the universe 14 billion years ago right
and for us to not treat every data every
Photon every particle that we detect
that would be a waste of this beautiful
opportunity that we have courtesy of the
technology that we built who else had
well said so Brian this is a pretty
exciting month for you your book losing
the Nobel Prize celebrates its one-year
anniversary and you know there's some
pretty amazing endorsements in here
right like Sir Roger Penrose just huge
hitters in the field so you know let's
let's ditch the water wings jump into
the deep end
and can you explain you know what's the
focus of the title bring us into kind of
behind the scenes what inspired you to
write losing the Nobel Prize and what
can readers expect
well I always had a love of books and a
love of popular science in general as a
kid I read a tremendous amount Carl
Sagan azimoff's Jane Goodall you know
these titans of popular science
communication but I never thought I
could really do it and I really probably
wouldn't have done it myself had it not
been for the fact that I was an
eyewitness to an event of such singular
importance in the history of cosmology
that and that one that I played such a
such a big role within and that's the
putative discovery of the spark that
ignited the Big Bang that we observed
today and we claimed in in 2014 that we
had witnessed the explosive origin of
the universe of period of time known to
physicists as inflation which is a form
of really mysterious energy that would
have pervaded the extremely early
universe we're not talking about a
billion years ago or you know or ten
billion years ago we're talking about
one trillionth of a trillionth of a
trillionth of a second after the Big
Bang it saw out the origin of the
universe
so like immediately after the
singularity then is that kind of what
we're looking her happy yes perhaps
immediately after that singularity about
which we know almost nothing right which
our discovery so exciting because it
would be the first experimental
observation of data of relic radiation
from that early origin of the universe
and data that could be obtained by no
other means and so this was the bicep2
instrument I had created what was called
the bicep one instrument which the
bicep2 instrument built upon used the
same design the same optics the same
sight at the bottom of the world at the
South Pole Antarctica and it had been
the predecessor for an upgrade called
bicep2 which was the instrument that
made headlines around the world with
millions of people witnessing it to to
really unravel what the universe might
have looked like the most early phase
and then that discovery had been told to
me and to many other people if
accomplished would result in a Nobel
Prize and so spoiler
you know from the book he's title you
could determine that I did not win the
Nobel Prize in fact but the Nobel Prize
title the the Nobel Prize in the title
losing the Nobel Prize is it as a double
has a double meaning which is that not
only did you know is the story a memoir
of what it's like to aspire to win a
Nobel Prize to achieve the ultimate and
humanity's accolades but also that there
are aspects of the Nobel Prize I came to
discover later both by being in the
running for one arguably and also being
asked to nominate the winners of the
Nobel Prize the following year that
those twin encounters really set me up
for a voyage of discovery into what was
the lost origin of the Nobel Prize
itself how did it come to be what has it
evolved into and how is it affecting the
way that science is done and in turn how
does that affect scientists so in short
I felt it was a book I could not write I
could not not write and it was a book
only I could write because I had played
such a crucial role in the scientific
encounter and also in the Nobel Prize
you know kind of run-up and then day
Newmont
and how my suggestions to reform the
Nobel Prize have redounded hopefully to
the benefit of the Nobel Prize itself
and only time will tell at that so it's
been a controversial book it's in it's
been a popular book a best-seller in
terms of popular science books in
astronomy and yeah as you mentioned I
was honored to get tremendous number of
blurbs from the most eminent science the
world including Brian Greene and Sir
Roger Penrose Martin Murray David
Spergel and many other great scientists
in America and abroad that's amazing and
holy hell man
like you're the first person to ever
organically work the title of our
podcast into an explanation of your work
in your book so that was super cool
super cool thank you for doing my
homework I see what you did there and I
appreciate the hell out of that so
that's great so that's cool that's
really cool so like one thing that I
found really interesting when I was
digging up you know information on the
Internet and just like the over
all intent of the Nobel Prize it
basically seems that like the native
purpose of this accolade has kind of
been I suppose mutated over time right
so like maybe explain for our listeners
like just the overall background of the
Nobel Prize who created it why and then
maybe do you think that the original
intent of the Nobel Prize is alive and
well today just like maybe your thoughts
on the beneficial or potential negative
effects that the recognition holds
within the scientific community as a
whole yeah that's a that's a great
couple of questions so did question yes
Ari yeah that the Nobel Prize you know I
had always been aware of it because
there are so few people you know I give
this analogy you know there's only been
about two times as many people that have
ever gone into space as are currently
living Nobel Prize winners in physics so
it's incredibly rare thing that that if
if people have heard of they know it's
an incredible honor they know it's like
it signifies brilliance unquestioned
genius but they don't really know much
about how it began what its purpose was
and what it really is doing to science
and scientists today and I make the
analogy you know it's kind of like the
Oscars and the Emmys and the Grammys and
you know the Nickelodeon or you know
everything that could possibly be rolled
into one for scientists and it's only
given out in six different categories
including physics chemistry medicine and
literature piece and then they added
about seventy years after the first
Nobel Prizes this committee added a
nobel prize in economics and that has a
lot of controversy associated with it
sure but I came to realize that the
Nobel Prize had become almost sort of an
idol that that scientists themselves who
are predominantly atheist or agnostic at
best who certainly very few affirm
actively belief in a higher power so
that they were almost as guilty of
worshipping this gilded graven image of
Alfred Nobel the patron saint the
creator of the Nobel Prizes as any you
know religious adherent would be for any
religious iconography and so it became
kind of scary to me that so many of my
colleagues and friends including me
and I always admit I was the worst you
know the most afflicted by this disease
you know I consider Noble ISM which is
an obsession or affliction of wanting to
win the Nobel Prize and I start to
analyze myself psychologically why was
it so important to me and I came to
realize because of you know the the sort
of way that it's been elevated and the
than the way that it's really kind of
strayed from what Alfred Nobel
originally intended which was merely as
a way in 1901 the first Nobel Prizes
were given away and in physics the first
prize was given to William roentgen who
discovered x-rays so if I went back and
looked at the nobel prize will that
Alfred Nobel wrote in 1896 and this will
was amazing because it really recorded
what his what his intentions were for
the very future of humanity and that he
wanted science technology literature etc
to work for the benefit of mankind and
and that the discoveries that were to be
awarded by this prize were to be those
that had a inclination towards peace or
prosperity but making human life better
so the very first one given for the for
the x-ray obviously that had tremendous
benefit because it allowed people to see
into their bodies and detect maladies
and diagnosis and so forth and that was
clearly beneficial nowadays we've
strayed into the realm of really
abstract science which is you know I
would say on an abstract level is
beneficial to the human mind but another
level it is it is quite far removed from
what Alfred ball wanted and so I asked
myself this man who had no children no
wife that we know about
he gave this money all this fortune and
which would have made him you know his
riches like you know Steve Jobs or
somebody is today he gave this vast
fortune which he had accumulated from
creating Anna patenting dynamite and
that fortune was meant to kind of
reclaim his reputation than the Nobel
name and so it was a very small prize
very niche thing that's really taken
over the world and become a
multi-billion dollar industry and very
crucial to the fabric of science now
even though it was really started by one
guy and and even his original intentions
have really been subsumed and what's now
now become of this prize that bears his
name walk us through that I'm just
curious do you think that's like the
crippling effect of the Nobel Prize is
basically stemming from the fact that
it's become a status symbol or do you
think that it's potentially the cash
purse that's at play here like it's
almost like the monetization of the
space as a whole just kind of the way
our society looks at a thing whether
it's good or you know for-profit
nonprofit and it ends up being morphed
into this like well how can we how can
we leverage this and and you know you
utilize it to it advance our initiative
or increase our profitability or
whatever well maybe it's a combination
of the two depending on the individual
based on what motivates them I don't
know like based on your experience the
conversations that you've had with other
you know potential candidates who were
up for the Nobel or just people within
the circles that you run have you had
any conversations as to like what the
systemic cause for this is yeah
definitely I mean I speculate that in
the book I should say the book is mostly
a memoir of what it's like to do science
and an explanation of what modern
cosmology knows about the mysterious
ultra early evolution of the universe
and how that impacts the potential
future of the universe but there are
three chapters devoted to the Nobel
Prize itself and what could be done to
reform it and really the monetary
benefit is relatively you know not to
sound you know snobbish but it's very
small in that it could be split three
ways among three people at most which is
not what Alfred Nobel wanted he wanted
to go to one person so they changed it
later in life to make it three people
but I think that may make things worse
because you know it's like if you're not
the one person who gets it well you're a
really good you know group of them maybe
a thousand other people on your project
who didn't win it but there's three
people that want it well I really should
did more than that person and so it
really has created a lot of acrimony and
actually some studies suggest that a
Nobel Prize is detrimental to
collaboration because these
collaborations dissolve after they one
person wins that are three people win it
and the other 27 to a thousand you know
48 people don't win it but
getting back to the actual impetus so
the money's a million dollars split
three ways if you live in America the
government takes half of that so you're
roughly talking about 160 K it's not
gonna change your lives so it's
definitely not the monetary Shadow sure
however I point out you know the Oscars
have no financial award associated with
them so if you win Best Actor you get
zero money as far as I know you get the
Statue you get a goodie basket that's
worth 20 grand or whatever but you don't
get a golden medal and you don't get a
you know a million dollars potentially
if you win it by yourself so so it can't
only be about that so it must be about
the prestige and who does the prestige
redound - well it goes mostly to the the
winners but it also goes in huge amount
to the people that supported the winners
in other words the funding agencies like
the universities or whatever that their
work yeah and you can find that in the
rankings of universities and funding
agencies in the United States NASA or
you know universities like mine the list
you know how many Nobel Prize winners
are on the current teaching roster how
many people won the Nobel Prize after
being at UC San Diego and I have no
problem with the people that want it
they don't select themselves you're
actually forbidden the only rule I got
when I nominated winners was like wasn't
able to nominate myself so that was very
helpful in eliminating at least one
person out you know 7 billion people in
the world but but at any rate the the
the primary beneficiary I claim is the
Nobel Academy because you can't name
probably can't name another science
award or even close you certainly can't
name another peace award that comes
anywhere close to the Nobel Peace Prize
right and it's similar in all the fields
so it's become extremely important to
the national identity of Sweden and to
their National Academy and I came to
find that there's only about three or
four hundred people and around the whole
world most of them most of them are men
in Sweden that give are in charge of
giving away this prize every year
so like any monopoly the Nobel Prize
wants to protect and sustain its
monopoly so it does what it can to keep
the prestige as high as possible at
least the perception of prestige as high
as possible so they have YouTube
channels they televise it they have
their bill
a huge new expensive glitzy haul and
Stockholm where they're gonna award the
prize just like the Oscars the Oscars
are not you know there's no God given
dictate that you know so-and-so is Best
Actress in a film it's just these people
suggested it and now the Oscars have a
brand that they also have to burnish and
so I do believe that one of the greatest
beneficiaries is the Nobel Prize
institution itself Wow Wow so let's talk
current cosmological projects that are
happening in your world you know we know
you have a lot of things going on but
you are currently Co leading to
international projects that are
searching for B modes so let's start
with an explanation of B modes and why
extra electromagnetic radiation is to
furthering our understanding of the
universe yeah so what's interesting
about astronomy is that it's very
difficult to do a true experiment in
other words we can't like change the
temperature of the Sun and see how that
affects the orbit of mercury or do
another experiment where we look at if
the universe had 10% more hydrogen what
would the status of a certain type of
chemical abundance be like so unlike
every other you know field of science
there's no way to vary a given variable
everything we get we have to receive it
comes to us either in the form of light
or now waves of gravity or perhaps
meteorites and that's it there's very
few other things you know particles and
photons really are essentially the main
source of messengers that collect and
bring information to the earth so we
have to be very judicious and efficient
about collecting this very faint light
and heat that comes from distant sources
in the universe we do have one advantage
over say archaeologists which is that we
have a time machine at our disposal so
every cell every telescope that sees
light or microwaves in my case or
infrared light or etc is actually
peering back the way that things look at
some time in the past it could be eight
minutes in the past when you look at the
Sun through a solar filter it could be a
million years in the past if you look at
the Andromeda galaxy or it could be 14
billion years if you look back to the
beginning of time in the early universe
that's what we do now the question is
how do you how does that tell us about
what happened at the very beginning of
time well in our case we're looking not
only at light itself which has been
stretched and in lengthened as the
universe expanded and cooled off from
this firey hellscape that must have been
present in the early universe and we
know that for a fact based on the amount
of certain elements that we see in the
universe we know how hot the universe
was and its earliest moments but if you
go very far back to that trillionth of a
trillionth of a trillionth of a second
after the initial singularity if such a
thing existed we're not sure singularity
existed then you come upon a time when
the universe was so small that it is
impossible for the force of gravity not
to be present what's called a quantum
state so most other forms of forces of
nature's of light electricity magnetism
etc etc are have a theory called the
quantum theory which ascribes a certain
probabilistic interpretation to the
various things that you can observe so
the probability of observing a given
particle depends on certain quantum
properties known as a wavefunction we
are trying to probe the wave function of
the universe shortly after it came into
existence and that wavefunction in
theory contains and encrypts and encodes
a lot of information about how the
universe will evolve in the deep future
so the exact type of information that
we're looking for is a form of a wave of
gravity which is the last and perhaps
only force that may not be unified with
the other forces of nature there's four
fundamental forces of nature electricity
magnetism then two different types of
nuclear force and then gravity we don't
know if gravity has a quantum form to it
that's never been discovered if we can
find it it would be the you know
so-called discovery of the theory of
everything
again that's an open source of research
that my colleagues and I are interested
in so the signal itself we're looking
sort of for the smoking gun
that would indicate whether or not the
universe began in this expansion on
inflation and The Smoking Gun is
predicted to be a background of
radiation but not in the form of light
or microwaves even but in the form of
gravitational waves and if they're
present they produce what are called B
modes which are a type of twisting
swirling form of polarization that I
described in the book and why it's so
important so the logic is the following
if we detect these B modes this swirling
twisting property of the Cosmic
Microwave Background light then that
will imply the universe had these waves
of gravity at an extremely early appts
evolution if that is true then the
universe must have undergone a period of
expansion called inflation and if
inflation is true it's almost
unavoidable that one has encounters
what's known as the multiverse which
means that there might be not just you
know eight just wave eight other eight
planets in our solar system and hundred
billion stars in our galaxy 100 billion
galaxies and the observable universe it
might be that there's a hundred billion
a trillion a quadrillion or an infinite
number of universes in what's called the
multiverse so and that has tremendous
ramifications and ripple effects in all
forms of science including maybe
extending into pure philosophy and
metaphysics and certainly into the realm
of theology and the notions of the
existence of God so I think all these
things are really fascinating things to
think about and it's amazing that
technology can finally answer this
question because we thought for
thousands of years the universe was
eternal static then we realized that was
changing now we are sort of unsure
whether or not the universe had a single
origin and if so what preceded it if
anything and then if not was there a
cycle a cyclic nature to the universe
and did that evolve are you talking
about like multiple banks theory there
basically yeah so there's multiple
universes you could have in space and
that's called the multiverse where
they're parallel universes and there's
multiple different ways to have parallel
universes you could have parallel
universes in the same place in space you
could have parallel universes in
different places of space and then you
could have cyclic universes where you
cycle from a Big Bang to a Big Crunch to
another
and that those types of models have been
around for a long time but now we're
sort of able to not prove them but
perhaps more interestingly falsified
them and exactly exactly and we are
gonna come back full circle to Big
Crunch Big Bounce all those things I
just have to ask you though like your
field specifically you guys work within
some parameters of some numbers that
just hurt the noodle straight up right
like when you guys are talking about is
like the like the the distance and like
just like trillionth of a trillionth of
a trillionth of a thing like how the
hell do you even wrap your head around
these things like when I watch a ton of
documentaries about the universe and
like looking at just like different ways
that we could potentially get to
different star systems in the future
when we're starting to talk about
light-years and we talk about the
distance and like how long it would
actually take human beings to get to a
different star system based on our
current technology and then if you you
know apply a coefficient to where if we
could get to 17% of the speed of light
or whatever it's like these are still
massive massive numbers like how the
hell do you do you even begin to wrap
your head around this stuff is it just
like time and practice or let or is
there like a mechanic in your brain that
you've been able to just like tap into
and make sense of it how does it work
for you well it's interesting because if
you if you actually think about it I
think it'll be very difficult to you
know from from a fresh start
every time thinking about something to
then go into and try to unravel its
deepest nature but on the other hand if
you can make analogies between things
that are more familiar you know we talk
about four dimensions of what's called
space-time it really it's impossible for
human beings even to really truly
conceive of three dimensions I mean we
see our eyes have retinas in the back
right and those retinas are basically
planar surfaces two-dimensional surfaces
of cells of rods of cones and those two
having two retinas and separated by a
couple of inches allows our brain very
cleverly to synthesize a sense of depth
perception but we're not actually seeing
into the table in front of you right
we're seeing we're seeing kind of around
it and how it diminishes with distance I
mean
Herbert that as as depth but in reality
we're synthesizing a three-dimensional
image from two two-dimensional images
now try to imagine synthesizing a
four-dimensional universe from two
two-dimensional images is basically
impossible so what we do is we make
analogies we start with lower dimensions
simpler forms we make things abstract we
translate and build mathematical models
for the universe and then we ask are
there any astronomical observations that
can illuminate no pun intended the
aspects of the model that we don't know
so there's always going to be parameters
and inputs into the model say you
believe the the Sun it takes eight
minutes for light to travel from the
earth to the Sun or from the Sun to the
earth
well that is predicated on some
measurement of the speed of light which
you cannot you don't get that from some
other law of physics you have to measure
that and put that into an equation which
says distance equals rate times time and
so that is an input into your model and
then you look for deviations from that
model but you can never actually prove
that model is correct because it's
always possible for the model to have
some features that are unobservable with
your current level of precision or
within the commensurate with the
uncertainty of the known parameter in
that case the speed of light has some
uncertainty associated with it so we we
make analogies we we we don't like have
super enormous brains we make models of
things and then we explore the
ramifications assuming the models are
true and we most of the time are looking
for departures from the model in other
words you'd be much more interesting to
find that distance isn't equal to rate
times time than it is with you know
outside the realm of uncertainty
associated as I described or allow Wow
let's let's take a second and try to
explore some of the origins of the
universe and looking at the early infant
stages of the earliest moments of the
universe so you're essentially looking
back in time if you know if time itself
is a singular flow how long has the
light that you're observing taking the
travel to where we can observe it yeah
so what we are doing when we look back
in space
we're looking back in time and the way
that you can sort of convince herself of
that if you weren't you know you guys
are pretty young but if you think back
to the Apollo moon landing when
astronauts were on the moon 225 thousand
miles from Earth
they would say something on the moon and
they would take about a second and a
half four you know Houston to
communicate with them and so the
round-trip was about three seconds in
this communication and that's because
radio waves are a form of
electromagnetic radiation has nothing to
do with nuclear you know fusion or
anything like that it's just what we
call waves that travel at the speed of
light and this form of radiation that
that we're looking for potentially came
at the very you know earliest instant
after the Big Bang if you've ever
thought about how the universe
originated it may have come along with
it the beginning of time in other words
the beginning of what we can observe may
be the only instance of a creation of a
universe that we can ever observe and so
far and in that case we could never look
back before that period of time because
you're asked well what happened on the
Tuesday before the Big Bang it doesn't
make sense but there are models of the
universe so-called cyclic models or
bouncing models or quasi steady state
models that produce universes that arise
like phoenixes I don't know what's the
plural of Phoenix fina from the previous
universe and so in that case it may be
possible to not only find evidence for
another universe but actually that
pre-exists of our universe but in some
sense have evidence for the state and
physical nature of that universe in
other words not just that it existed
it's like you know your great kakuka
grandparent existed but you don't know
what he or she was like but imagine you
had like a book or a video or you know
something handed out through time that
would give you a lot more information
obviously be a lot more interesting to
you but just knowing that they existed
would be very interesting as well and
how and where so courtesy of the fact
that the speed of light is extremely
fast but is the ultimate speed limit in
the universe that you cannot exceed when
you look back in space or listen with a
radio wave the example of the Apollo
you're actually perceiving things not as
they are instantaneously now but when
they were in that condition that they
produce this signal that you're now
detecting so in the case of the cosmic
microwave background radiation this 3
Kelvin background there comes in all
directions from all parts of the cosmos
that light is the oldest form of
electromagnetic light that you could
possibly see and so if you could build a
telescope that can see it which means
convert it into digital signals that you
could then pictures out of and then
analyze the pictures those signals can
then tell you about the composition of
the universe about the age of the
universe about the size of the universe
and very curious things such as you know
what's called the curvature of the
universe is it possible to shoot two
laser beams from from two laser guns
held at your hips and have them
eventually come into contact with one
another cross through each other you
know far far away from Earth and the
distant universe that depends on what's
known as the curvature of the universe
and so all these different properties
and more we learn about using this most
ancient form of light and in particular
we're hoping we can learn more about the
most ancient light which could be this
form of not light but waves of gravity
so ancient radiation the so-called
cosmic rabbit a tional wave background
which may come from all directions in
space man like just trying to wrap my
head around it and it's it's it's so
exact so let's let's go back to earlier
in our conversation before the break we
were like starting to talk about
expansion of the universe right so I
think what would be helpful is first for
some of our listeners who may be like
aren't super versed in that concept
maybe just give us a loose explanation
of what expansion is what does that
theory look like and I think that's
gonna T us up for my next question
nicely sure so when we look out in the
universe we observe now with great
certainty that there's more than just
the Milky Way galaxy that we inhabit
sure so our solar system is a single
star populated with eight you know major
planets and you know perhaps millions of
little tiny
fragments comments planets planetoids
and that's one of a hundred billion
stars in the Milky Way galaxy we look
out in space we see a hundred billion
other galaxies in the universe so rough
math gives you a population of about a
hundred billion squared stars in the
observable universe in other words in
the universe that has had enough time to
send light and existence that they exist
these stars and galaxies to our
telescopes on earth just now then if you
want to really blow your mind multiply
by ten or a thousand for the number of
planets that such systems might have you
get numbers like you know a trillion
billion you know possible planets in the
observable universe it's just a truly
astronomical numbers now when you look
at every single one of those galaxies
with a possible exception of about 12
other one a twelve out of the hundred
billion galaxies that we can see all
hundred billion minus twelve are moving
away from us they're expanding away from
us in the interpretation of space
between us getting bigger now what about
the twelve that I mentioned you know
it's kind of like well you've got thirty
teeth or so in your mouth but you lose
one that's the one you're gonna focus on
right so everyone knows that why are
those other twelve not expanding well
that's because they're so close to us in
the Milky Way is massive enough or
they're massive enough that we'll be
attracted to them and we'll share kind
of a common fate where eventually our
galaxy will collide and coalesce with
these other galaxies much like how we're
gonna collide with Andromeda in like a
massive amount of years but like that's
basically what what is great yeah yeah
keep paying your taxes because that's
gonna be a couple trillion years
potentially
so exactly so now if that interpretation
is correct then in the future things
will be more diffused and spread out we
actually know that since the time of
Hubble in 1929 and the universe is
expanding in the sense and that brought
about the natural corollary to that idea
which is that in the past the universe
is smaller so yesterday the universe was
slightly smaller than it is today
a billion years ago was a lot smaller
and 13.8 billion years ago it was really
smaller it was perhaps you know a
thousand a thousand times smaller and
the question is what if you go
- time equals zero would it not be an
infinite amount smaller than our
universe is now in other words wouldn't
it be essentially a singularity and
that's an unknown question in other
words we really don't know what happened
in the universe until we get to its ripe
old age of about three minutes after the
order came into existence so it could
have come into existence from the from
the pre-existing universe that may have
collapsed and crunched to form enough
seed material for our universe to rise
like that Phoenix yeah or it could come
from a singularity which is sort of like
a white hole which is sort of a black
hole in Reverse spewing out matter
energy in all directions and causing an
expansion driven by this mysterious type
of energy which is acting like an
anti-gravitational force causing things
to expand so that's our interpretation
we're basically running back the movie
that currently shows things getting
farther apart and interpolating back to
early times they must have been a lot
closer together right right so you're
just trying to quit and Tarantino the
thing to figure out what it all means
right so so what implications you know
does the expansion of the universe have
essentially for the fate of our universe
itself you know we've seen a lot of
conflicting theories out there you have
Professor Brian Cox he's explained out
the universe is gonna continue to expand
when when all of the stars died
essentially like the heat death of the
universe itself
taking all life with them into the
darkness another theory about Big Crunch
or the Big Bounce which basically sees
the reverse effects of the Big Bang or
some great contraction or the collapsing
of the known universe that triggers
another big bang scenario so based on
your research you know what's what's
your take on the expansion of our
universe and what's to follow
right so what's so interesting about the
universe that we observe is that it is
it is expanding it is getting bigger as
we look out in galaxies nearby are you
know with absolute certainty are moving
away from us except for those 12 that I
mentioned before those misfits that are
getting attracted to us now if you think
about how the universe could evolve the
different ways
theorists of cosmology are very creative
they can they can think about different
alternatives that can avoid the problem
that is causing the this experience that
we seem to see if the universe getting
larger what is so fascinating to us is
that there the fate of the universe in
the deep future is determined by this
substance called dark energy which seems
to pervade the universe in all regions
that we can observe and even though it's
very tenuous even though there's very
little of it right now on earth in our
bodies you know surrounding us we know
almost nothing about it and yet because
of it it's acting as if the universe is
being inflated again the exact thing is
that the earth is expanding and not only
is it expanding so Hubble observed these
galaxies moving away at a constant rate
but this dark energy substance about
which we know extremely little is acting
like a cosmic accelerator being floored
in other words you hold your foot on the
pedal of a constant position you'll
speed up to some you know maximum speed
but then you want to accelerate you got
to push it further down to the floor
sure the universe is not exactly
expanding you know at the pedal to the
metal but in the very deep future
because of it being controlled by this
dominant energy form called dark in the
universe will continue to expand and it
will expand at an ever-increasing rate
unless it may be that the universe has
this has this weird feature that the
dark energy can mysteriously decay and
go away and if that happens it may be
possible not only for the universe to
stop accelerating for us to avoid this
frigid that Brian Cox is talking about
the number three favorite Brian of my
kids in terms of astronomers where do
you rank in that I mean obviously dad's
number one then you probably Brian green
then we got Brian Cox is that break
nailed it
yeah thank god neil degrasse tyson so so
I'm wondering you know if we have if we
have you know a universe that is so
mysterious
though we really don't know what this
properties of this dominant form of
energy is dark energy I'm wondering you
know how can we say with great with
great certainty what will happen in the
future and if you're wondering along
with me it's because we really don't
know we do we can't say with certainty
but Brian Cox has said we can't say with
certainty that the universe won't you
know rika lapse on itself if this if
this dark energy dissolves away and
fades into energy of the ordinary kind
you know the form of energy that you're
more familiar with just ordinary energy
which acts attractively in the universe
and store pulse so these are open
questions that we hope that our
experiment this one called the Simon's
Observatory which I'm the director of
we're hoping that that project will shed
light again no pun intended on this most
mysterious question about this medium
this material this very very mysterious
force called dark energy that is
seemingly driving the universe apart and
how that will potentially impact the
longevity of our current observable
universe so basically how fast right now
do we know is the universe expanding
like what is the rate at which it it's
the expansion is taking place it's funny
that you say that because a couple of
months ago or maybe a year or so ago we
wouldn't have really had any
controversial aspect about answering
that question we would have said the
universe is expanding and it's expanding
at a rate that depends on how far away
something is from us so something that's
twice as far from us as a galaxy that's
twice as far away from Earth as given
Galla as the Andromeda galaxy you know
would be expanding two times as fast as
the Andromeda galaxy and that was
expressed in terms of what's called the
Hubble the Hubble constant which
expressed the expansion rate of the
universe given by these very strange
sounding units of 72 kilometers per
second per megaparsec distance so a
galaxy that's one mega parsec away from
us would be expanding at a rate of 72
kilometers per second they're very fast
not as fast as the speed of light but
but quite fast now if a galaxy was twice
that far to mega parsecs away a mega
parsecs about
three million light years so a galaxy
that six million light years away would
be expanding at a rate of a hundred and
forty four kilometers per second etc
until you get way way out in the
distance and that distance would then
have a would would lead to an implied
expansion velocity equal to or greater
than the speed of light let's that we
won't get into that right now but but
nowadays we're finding that that 72
number is controversial so two or three
years ago really was accepted by all
cosmologists now we're having
controversial debates and and and poll
meetings and conferences dedicated to
why astronomers don't agree on that
value and in fact are so vehement in
their disagreement that they have to
have like whole workshops and and huge
papers written about why we're getting
two different types of results for this
very fundamental parameter in cosmology
which governs how fast things are
expanding away from us so out of
curiosity let's say that you know Big
Crunch is is what takes place after
expansion okay
and so the universe collapses in on
itself and earlier you had made the
comment that you know the the speed of
light is the fastest like that's the
speed limit of the universe right with
nothing can go faster than the speed of
light is it possible though that if dark
matter decays goes away does that allow
for like the breaking of the rules of
physics is so in so far that they could
the universe could collapse in on itself
faster than the speed of light or is it
gonna be a very similar rate of collapse
as as it was expansion like what what
does that collapse like theoretically
that's a very good question so this is
an open aspect of research and it comes
down slightly to the realm of like
sociology of science right now you know
a hundred years ago if you worked on an
expanding universe even Einstein would
say you're a crackpot and you're an
idiot and you shouldn't be allowed to
practice physics in fact he said that to
the man who first presented a theory of
an expanding universe based on on
Stein's own laws of what's called
general relativity sure and he said your
your math is good but
physics is atrocious he said to the
scylla maitre who is a Belgian Catholic
priest by the way who had kind of really
come up with evidence that the universe
might have had a singular origin and
that was much to the chagrin of Einstein
who thought the universe was static
essentially in existed forever now when
the universe was discovered to be
expanding he could no longer maintain
the universe was static because it
wasn't staying put it was changing with
time as Einstein then later refined his
theory he came up with this idea that
that this term that he had added to make
the universe constant and static was
essentially a blunder he called it
apocryphally perhaps his biggest blunder
now if we end up looking at the universe
nowadays we realized that it was a
blunder to say it was a blunder because
this same constant that eyes that
Einstein added is none other than the
dark energy that we see today or at
least it has the potential to be in this
constant form of energy that doesn't
change or dilute with time and the
universe seems to be producing for every
cubic metre that adds on to the
universe's size it produces a certain
amount of dark energy that seems to be
constant throughout the observable
universe
so we know a great deal about it we know
understand and and appreciate how the
effects of this thing will behave but we
don't know what it is so it's kind of
like what physicists used to call like
the ether or something like that in
their olden days so most people accept
there was a big bang almost every
cosmologists finds it inescapable that
there was a big bang and yet there are
physicists working on theories that
suggest there wasn't just one Big Bang
in other words you could have multiple
perhaps an infinite number of Big Bang's
such that on the average the universe is
sort of static because it just is
behaving cyclically so imagine like
these you know kind of iñigo the disco
as I'm sure you do Thursday yeah yeah
when there's a strobe light flashing
when you look at something that's
changing if the strobe is synchronous
with that rate of change of whatever
you're looking at you'll it'll look
static to you even though it's moving
and so we mechanics use that when they
look at your timing belt in your car etc
and
universe is looked at every trillion
years or so perhaps they would look
static to an observer who adds such you
know patience if you will and so it's
really fascinating to think about but
it's almost out of the mainstream of
cosmology that people observe and think
about these effects in order to really
understand how the universe began really
requires that you overthrow conventional
wisdom unless were these people like Sir
Roger Penrose or professor Paul
Steinhardt at Princeton and other people
have conjectured scenarios where the
universe could be actually cyclic on
very long timescales and they're very
much out of the mainstream but they're
very much you know more brilliant than
than I ever hope to be
so I have to take them seriously but as
I said we don't look to prove them right
because when you do that you are
susceptible to what's known as
confirmation bias that you may end up
seeing what you want to see even though
it doesn't really exist yeah when your
hand everything's a nail right exactly
so in our case we want to be very
dispassionate and look for evidence of
cyclic universes but perhaps to rule
them out may require an experiment
exactly like the Simon's Observatory so
one last question before we jump into a
few whimsical questions that I have
prepared for you today because you know
why the hell not so like just based on
your data your research what you're
currently seeing has the shape of the
landscape that you're working in are the
are these questions like questions that
can be answered within our lifetime in
your opinion or do you think that this
is going to be a continuation of
multiple generations working towards the
same common goal like like how close are
we to really understanding the fabric of
the cosmos the nature of reality the
universe as a whole
or like what are your thoughts there
yeah so there's a lot of different you
know crises that cosmologists and
physicists go through and I always joke
you know maybe we need a good
psychotherapist to help us with all of
our neuroses I don't know if you ever
saw Annie Hall but you know Woody
Allen's characters gets obsessed when
he's a kid because the universe is
expanding and actually be apart and then
as his mother says well Brooklyn's not
expanding you know
do your homework Brooklyn's not
expanding I feel that way too you know
there's kind of a practical aspect of
what we do and then there's a real
ethereal metaphysical aspect of what we
do and there are things that we may
never know and it's uncomfortable as a
scientist you know to think that there
are mysteries you know for which we will
never provide an answer on the other
hand it's also very pleasurable because
it means that there's all these puzzles
that are out there to solve and I don't
know if you know when I was a kid you
know if I ever solved like a Rubik's
Cube which I think I did once
you know I try to do it again and you're
like that's pointless like why would you
want to do is something you've already
done again like it doesn't do anything
for you but but actually it does because
every time you do it you recapture a
little bit of that taste of excitement
of doing it the first time and in our
case we have all these mysteries that
could be solved or may never be solved
for the first time so and one of those
is perhaps the origin of the universe is
it forever inscrutable is it hidden
behind this firewall of ignorance owing
to both its distance or perhaps its
faintness in a certain sense you know
the universe we think of the Big Bang is
this extremely violent event of which it
was but then you think of how much the
universe has expanded and diluted and
how little there is in the universe
today if I tell you that you know if you
go into the you know deep intergalactic
space and you have a box you know like a
size of a wardrobe box and a you know
that you might move from house to house
and you might find one proton or maybe
even half a proton inside that entire
box or one electron or inside that and
that's just incredibly minut there's
almost no way to comprehend how empty
space is yeah and how and how dilute it
is and how alone we may be I mean I'm a
might being a minority amongst my
colleagues and I think we're probably
the only intelligent civilization that
exists and may have ever existed and we
may only ever know of our ourselves is
the only intelligent species to have
existed doesn't mean that there might
not be life elsewhere right now perhaps
right underneath our noses but but on
the other hand you know signs of
technological life may be impossible to
ever gather let alone information about
another
universe that is potentially completely
unobservable and must be induced from
other knowledge that we glean so I you
know I personally find it exhilarating
but I know to other people it's
incredibly depressing sure sure well
there's such a difference between
microbial life and intelligent life -
right so it's like it's not an apples to
apples comparison for sure but no thank
you thank you for walking me through
that
holy hell man I want to get you back on
the show I want to make sure that we're
able to continue the conversation
because I have a billion other questions
I want to ask you I do have three
whimsical questions I want to hit you
with real quick yeah what is your
favorite celestial object right are we
looking at like pulsars quasars like
what what's the weirdest or most
intriguing or interesting thing that
you've been able to see when you're
observing the cosmos well for me it'll
always be it'll always be the moon and a
moon yeah the moon because that's really
the first thing that kindled my interest
as a scientist and led to the first bit
of scientific research that I ever did
back in the 80s when I woke up one night
and I saw this really bright light and
next to it was another kind of smaller
but equally bright light and I didn't
know what what it was I thought it was a
you know a plane but it never moved and
the moon was just so enticing it was
just fascinating to me I always wondered
as I'm sure you have you know why is it
that the moon always follows me wherever
I go and I later learned that was
because I'm you know the most important
person who's ever lived and no I'm just
now why that effect is true you know
owes to the distance and the size of the
moon and the earth but but but I'd
always wondered about that and it wasn't
until I was able to wait for a newspaper
those things printed on dead trees to
arrive this is 1984 or so sure that I
realized you know a week later almost
what I had seen was the moon and the
planet Jupiter and after immediately
after realized that I said about to get
my first telescope and looked at Jupiter
through through the telescope and saw it
had moons - and I had unwittingly
repeated this observation that my man
who became my my astronomical scientific
hero Galileo Galilei discovered the same
things now I'm not comparing myself to
him
he-he-hey achieved some slider degree of
fame than I did but but as I described
in my book I'm a fascination with
discovery and research and having to be
patient and wait to understand these
things now I've seen many beautiful
things through a telescope but that
first observation those observations
that I made with my eyes and with the
telescope really are what hooked me on
becoming an astronomer and took me
through the professional path that I'm
on today that's amazing and listen I got
to just be frank with you you know
Galileo yes big name made some solid
contributions to the scientific
community in the field in general but I
will say I appreciate the humility but
that dude was never on lost origins I'm
just I've just calling a spade a spade
just like Einstein you know the two of
them are known for making great
contributions but also they had a lot of
errors and blunders I already mentioned
Einstein's sure Galileo had his share
too and I talked about it and I say it's
really unfortunate because you know if
Einstein hadn't made those blunders he
could have had made a name for himself
sure sure sure okay so second whimsical
question okay favorite space slash
sci-fi movie in existence well I am the
co-director of the arthur c clarke
center for human imagination at the
university of california okay san diego
and you can you can search on the web we
have our own podcast and maybe someday
we'll do a we'll do a podcast a hostage
exchange where we'll know you know have
you on the podcast in our case we study
you know human imagination and how
prescient arthur c clarke lesser arthur
c clarke was and it's a real inspiration
barry his vision of both science and
fiction and writing from you know the
the 20th century to the 21st century and
so for me it's 2001 a space odyssey is
my favorite in the science fiction genre
very good and your mention of a you know
podcast hostage takeover in last season
we did one with cliff Dunning from Earth
Ancients and it was super cool and we
would be so down to do that so you just
you tell us when and where and we'll
make it happen
last one's a cool question for you
before we get into unpacking what it is
you're currently working on where people
can connect with you this one's the most
serious of them all though okay so
tonight I hope you're sitting
am sitting okay out of curiosity which
character from the Big Bang Theory do
you relate with the most if you had to
you have to pick one doesn't have to be
one of the main characters where I think
it could be Stuart it could be it could
be anybody but if you had to pick a cast
member or a character from that that
series who is it and why well I hate to
disappoint you but you know I don't
think I've ever seen a full episode of
The Big Bang Theory all right well I had
a strongly-worded emailed it how send
that to you afterwards just to express
my but it's okay so okay before we go
into you know how people can connect
with you online what you're working on
what not I think it'd be cool if they
have any you know younger listeners on
the show who are trying to you know look
at what they want to do with their life
they're very drawn to you know the
origins of humanity they're drawn to
science they're drawn to asking
questions and let's let's say that you
know part of them is really really
attracted to the cosmos the universe and
and and your field specifically what
advice do you have for that young
budding mind as it relates to how and
you know why they should continue to go
down this path ask these questions and
why astrophysics could potentially be a
field that is warranted for them yeah
well for me
astrophysics connects all aspects of
science into one and it's unique in that
respect in that we can talk about the
fundamental building blocks of matter
quarks leptons etc we can talk about the
entire that which are the smallest
structures in the universe and maybe
strings microscopic super strings and
then we can talk about the entirety of
the universe itself so the smallest
scales - the biggest skills we can talk
about the chemistry of the universe how
different elements were formed inside of
stars or in the Big Bang itself we can
talk about biology we can understand how
life might have originated on earth and
if it may exist on other planets if it
does exist on other planets what kind of
type of signals might they send we can
study information theory we can build
telescopes we can build technology we
can build theoretical models so it's so
all-encompassing but to me the most
delightful thing is that all the
can then have ramifications in
philosophy perhaps in theology and so
it's the biggest possible subject you
can study with a no offense to any of my
colleagues professions and their
subfields of and disciplines within
physics or even within astronomy it
takes all sorts of astronomers to make
the models and or on theories that we
have in the universe so for me building
telescopes gave me this connection to
from the smallest things to the biggest
things and really whet my appetite for
research for study and I always say you
know for the young people out there you
should really get a telescope you should
get a telescope and get an app you know
three dollar app I'm sure there's
millions of them out there that will
tell you what things to look at now when
you look at them you're not gonna see
this Hubble Space Telescope image you
know that looks almost three-dimensional
and and it's just gonna blow your mind
it's gonna be a smudge it's gonna be a
bright dot it's gonna be all the you
know very much a letdown except when you
realize that your eye is connected to
the greatest minds in human history
stretching back to Galileo all the way
back to the ancient Greeks and in so
doing your mind is part of this
unfurling chain of scientists that
stretched from the deep deep past
through you my young listener out there
into the ever-increasing unfurling
future and so for about $50 on the
online store you can after you buy my
book you can buy a little telescope and
that telescope with an app will show you
some really cool things and it's a
really golden age now where Elon Musk
and Jeff Bezos and all these other
people are putting you know potentially
manned space missions into space so if
you want to be an astronaut there's no
better scholastic training that you can
get in astronomy and so I really do
believe that it is one of the most
wonderful sciences to be a part of and
it can be done quite cheaply you know
try getting your own particle
accelerator at Amazon you know you won't
be able to do it and and you won't be
able to make those instantaneous
gratifying discoveries that you can with
astronomy you can see through a small
telescope even more things in Galileo
or Isaac Newton saw
and think of the contributions they made
even from the middle of New York City
you can do it you can see the moons of
Jupiter the rings of Saturn and the
crater every crater on the moon that
Galileo could see so it's really quite a
wonderful time and you couple that with
all the free lectures that are available
online on the Astronomy it's a golden
age to be a young person thinking about
doing astronomy in their future that's
amazing and I think it's important to
point out that even with light pollution
in a city like New York you can still
see things through the telescope you
don't have to go to some desolate
location to be able to turn your
telescope towards the night sky and
really just take it all in you know what
I mean that's that's absolutely right
all right so before we part ways I know
that your time is precious and I don't
want to burble any more of it what are
you currently working on but is there
another book in the works
how can people connect with you and your
work online is there website social
channels just kind of walk us through
that real quick yeah so I'm on all the
normal social channels i'm dr dr bright
Bryan Keating on Twitter Instagram and
YouTube and I'm putting out I'm trying
to put out a video a week or so on
YouTube short videos about the research
or books that I'm reading things I think
people find interesting and then for I
have a mailing list that I send out
about four or five emails a year and for
those of you out there who are listening
if you sign up at Bryan Keating dot-com
VR I am Ketan ke a TI ng comm I will
select at random three winners will
receive a genuine piece of space dust
that's 4.3 billion years old and this is
a meteorite from the ancient solar
system the pre-planetary solar system
which I've collected these are small
little samples but this is the most some
of the most ancient material you can get
and it plays a very vital role in my
book it's sort of the villain of my book
in the form of this space dust signal
and you'll hopefully become endeared
with this substance and it's one of the
few pieces of tangible material you can
actually hold from the distant universe
so that's three random signers up if
that's a word for my mailing list and
you can do that at Bryan Keating comm
for your first name just use your first
name for your last name put lost origins
they I will send I will send a genuine
piece of space dust
to your listeners that I randomly
selected your listeners that's amazing
you guys know what to do hop on the
website sign up for the newsletter throw
lost origins in there and man get
yourself some space dust that's that's
incredible that's so cool thank you for
doing that for our audience I appreciate
the hell out of that so listen up this
conversation was so intriguing I
appreciate your time so much I know that
you're a busy busy guy I also know that
you're you know a family man and so
thank you for carving time out for us
today CK and I enjoyed the hell out of
this conversation we definitely have to
get you back on the show in the future
cuz like I said earlier I still have a
billion questions I will continue to add
to that list Brian this has been one of
the coolest conversations thank you so
much for spending time with us this
Likes we've looked forward to this for
for a while and you know thank you for
spending so much time digging so deep
into stuff that's so heady but let's
keep in touch and we will definitely
make that happen soon absolutely let's
not make it another billion years before
we get together damn straight well thank
you so much Brian we appreciate it
absolutely my pleasure injury by now